l'actualité judiciaire avec demain une
première dans les annales de la justice
française un troisième procès aux
assises pour le même homme et pour les
mêmes faits patrick dils sera rejugé en
appel
il compare à lyon pour répondre du
meurtre de deux enfants commis près de
metz fagnot vernis frédéric ben c'était
il ya dix mois
lors du deuxième procès aux assises de
patrick dils il pensait peut être
innocenté verdict 25 en prison
patrick dils eux qui a fait appel va
donc être rejugé pour la troisième fois
quinze ans après les meurtres de deux
enfants sur une voie ferrée à
montigny-lès-metz
les gendarmes ont repris l'enquêté à
zéro cent quarante témoins auraient
entendu de nouvelles expertises
les enquêteurs s'interrogent sur l'heure
du crime qu'ils estiment plus
vraisemblable une heure plus tôt or à
cette heure patrick dils se trouve à 70
kilomètres de là francis heaulme le
tueur en série était quant à lui bien là
dans ce créneau horaire de plus de
pêcheurs affirment l'avoir trouvée à
quatre kilomètres du lieu du crime
le visage ensanglanté pour les parents
de patrick dils ces nouveaux éléments
devraient permettre d'acquitter leur
fils on devrait arriver à ce que les 900
de patrick jean prouvé et blanche et
surtout un papa il faut qu'il soit
blanchi leurs logiciels est là il s'est
terminé non conspué tout le monde fait
des fautes à pourquoi il il n'avoue pas
qu'ils ont fait une faute avant de se
rétracter patrick dils a reconnu les
deux meurtres plusieurs fois alors
depuis 16 ans les familles des victimes
sont persuadé de sa culpabilité
ça me pèse énormément plus caresses et
la nouvelle enquête ne changent rien à
leurs convictions
nous ce qu'on veut c'est d'avoir un cap
et a faim c'est lui mais il a donné des
précisions terrible jeu je redis des
précisions que celle seule la façade
tous les connaître
patrick dils a trois semaines pour
prouver son innocence
c'est le procès de la dernière chance